during the Super Bowl Lady Gaga shocked
the world by not taking an enormous
political dump all over the stage she
warbled her usual agglomeration of over
produced garbage and she strutted around
the stage like a maimed llama wearing
Beyonce's old outfits and she also
appeared to commit suicide two times in
the same routine
but although Laura Ingraham thought that
she went political she actually didn't
Laura Ingraham originally tweeted Gaga
had ignored the phrase under God and her
recitation of the pleasure legions but
Lady Gaga actually said it and although
Lady Gaga did sing Born This Way which
has officially been named now the second
worst song ever penned after John
Lennon's Imagine the halftime show was
actually pretty free of politics and
this drove some people on the left out
of their minds
here's Michael wood of the Los Angeles
time quote Lady Gaga misses her Super
Bowl moment to say something profound
would complain the 30 year old singer
offered up a disappointing 12-minute
medley they lacked any edge or attention
you wish she'd taken in more of what was
going on offstage here's Chris Richards
at the Washington Post
Lady Gaga calls herself a rebel but at
the Super Bowl she played it safe he
then complimented Beyonce's ridiculous
Pro Black Panthers routine at the Super
Bowl last year and he wrote quote with
forceful elegance Beyonce had set a
precedent for what could be done on this
stage musically and politically by
comparison Gaga whiffed here's Pete leg
of the Milwaukee journal-sentinel
Gaga's overall performance overshadowed
a potentially meaningful moment the word
safe appears in reviews from Variety the
New York Daily News which said that Gaga
landed flat Newsday and a bevy of other
outlets for today's media it is a sin to
merely perform the hits from which
you're known if you're given a big stage
you must immediately begin spouting
protest lines from the women's March or
your Acela no matter how many times you
campaigned with Hillary Clinton you will
be forced to take a position to shout
about politics to destroy your audience
goodwill by insulting at least half of
them
Lady Gaga didn't so here's a phrase I
never thought I'd say thanks Lady Gaga
most Americans who are watching the
Superbowl run in a break from the
partisan ranker that now consumes most
of our event-driven lives you provided
that break that's a statement in and of
itself at a time when everybody needs to
calm down and take a deep breath I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay so we're gonna get to the Super
Bowl in just one second we're also gonna
get to Donald Trump and his comments
about Russia Donald Trump has been very
active on Twitter I think that he
realized everybody had the weekend off
and decided okay you know what
now's my time back to the Twitter while
everyone is away he grabbed back his
blackberry hacked into it and began
tweeting out random things so we'll get
to all of that because there's a lot to
get to plus he didn't interview the bill
o'reilly that was quite insane but we'll
get to all of that you know good trump
bad Trump the whole shebang but first we
have to say thank you to our sponsors
over a blue apron they are the number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country their goal is to
make great home cooking available to
everyone and accessible to everyone so
you don't know how to cook doesn't
matter so long as you got some pots and
pans they send you the ingredients they
send you the recipes it's all super
fresh and the recipes are all top-notch
they have established partnerships with
over 150 local farms fisheries and
ranchers across the United States so if
you're a bi American higher American
person than blue apron is for you and by
the way if you cook together it creates
strong bonds I know this I actually do
this with my with my three year old she
likes to crack eggs whenever we do that
routine but if you're if you're somebody
who is who likes to cook with the family
and this is a perfect opportunity to do
so all the recipes are cook about in 40
minutes or less they have a bunch of
meals that they rotate in and out to new
meal every day basically they featured
upcoming meals like cashew chicken
stir-fry with Tango mandarins and
jasmine rice an udon noodle soup I don't
know that is with miso and soft-boiled
eggs but it sounds really good they they
have all of these really interesting
recipes and it makes you sound like a
gourmet even though you really don't
know what you're doing because they do
all of the work for you they put
together the recipe they put together
the ingredients and they tell you
exactly what to do if you can follow a
step-by-step instruction manual then
you'll be able to make fantastic food
for your family for less than $10 per
person and they deliver those seasonal
recipes along with those pre portion
ingredients that's healthy it's it's
delicious and it's a lot it's a lot
cheaper than going out to eat at a
restaurant if you go and you check out
this week's menu it gets even cheaper
first three meals you get free with free
shipping if you go to blue apron comm
slash Shapiro blue apron comm slash
Shapiro blue apron it's a better way to
cook okay so I was the unluckiest person
in America yesterday other than Matt
Ryan I was I
I was on a plane for virtually the
entire Superbowl because that's why
we're now in a deep dark dank hotel room
and we brought Mathis was unlucky enough
to have to travel with me so both of us
missed the Superbowl in its entirety I
watched a lot of it last night after we
got to the hotel I watched some of it
this morning and of course it figures
that the one time I missed the Super
Bowl it ends up actually being a
phenomenal game but there's a lot to
talk about at the Super Bowl I talked
about Lady gaga before first of all I do
have to say that my favorite moment from
the Super Bowl was the very beginning of
her halftime show and it appeared that
she'd actually finished her musical
career it sort of looked like this yeah
there it is
yeah I thought for a second I was like
wow that's the shortest halftime show in
history but it turns out no there was
more she actually did it again later at
the very end she also jumped off a high
object and she she survived which you
know is good I suppose and and so there
was that but she didn't end up being
political everybody thought she was
gonna be super duper political the
entire left is very disappointed because
everything must be political now it is
imperative that all the things have to
be political it is deeply important so
she was she was saying before hand that
she was going to do all sorts of stuff
about inclusion and on equality and
instead she basically went up there and
she's saying god Bless America and this
land is your land with a bunch of drones
in the background and then she danced as
I say like like crippled hyena while
singing her patented highly produced
auto-tune song so that was not the
actual political side of the of the
Super Bowl and in the game itself you
don't need me to do the analysis of the
game although I did I will say I think I
did have the most the most politically
oriented tweet the most retweeted
politically oriented tweet of the
evening it's now been retweeted I think
27,000 times
so just shows you that apparently I
should go into sports commentator a
sports commentator mode more often I
tweeted I can't believe the guy with the
foreign model wife and a sketchy history
with the rules just one after being
written huh and then hos retweeted that
has now been retweeted 27,000 times so
that is you know says something in any
case the real political side was the ad
so here's something I've never
understood about the advertising at the
Superbowl first of all you pay
all this money and then obviously get a
lot to earn the media so if you do an ad
people are talking about it gets
replayed now online it's worth the money
but why would you absolutely ignore half
the audience why would you ignore half
the audience a lot of these ads were
clearly geared very clearly geared
toward the the audience of the left and
not in geared toward the audience of the
right and the NFL audience is going to
tend to skew to the right because a lot
of the NFL audience exists between the
coasts and this is why it's always been
weird to me that you have like Beyonce
and Lady Gaga playing halftime and my
guess is that if you plant Leonard
Skynyrd playing halftime you please more
the NFL audience than you would if you
had Lady gaga
playing playing that halftime show in
any case some of the ads were very
political and the one that got a lot of
attention was outies Equal Pay ad here's
what that sounded and looked like what
do I tell my daughter
do I tell her that our grandpa's worth
more than our grandma
that her dad is worth more than her mom
do I tell her that despite her education
her drive her skills her intelligence
she will automatically be valued as less
than every man she ever meets
or maybe I'll be able to tell her
something different she drove in and out
the Audi of America's committed to equal
pay for equal work progress is for
everyone so what that has to do with
Audi I have no clue whatsoever I'm just
confused as to why Audi thinks that
driving away in an Audi makes up for the
fact that she's gonna be paid 71 cents
on the dollar and have to bear children
from her womb but but it's but
nonetheless that was hilarious about
this Audi runs this ad and so people
immediately begin slapping audi on
facebook and twitter and saying guys you
pay women less than you pay men and so
now d immediately writes back like
within 20 minutes of the sea a drowning
they immediately write back
well if you take into account the
different job positions in the number of
hours works and actually pay women men
the same it's like right because that's
for everyone it's not just true of Audi
like if you can name the companies that
are not doing that then you're gonna
need to actually talk to federal
investigators because that's a crime
right that's that's actually against
federal law you're not allowed to
discriminate on the basis of sex under
federal law but that's but so I say out
he runs this ad and it immediately falls
apart so that was funny that was one of
their political ads and just shows how
ridiculous the pandering is and when the
left says fake news that's fake news I
mean this pay this wage gap myth has
been a myth for a long time in 2010 in
147 out of 150 biggest cities in America
women were paid more than men if they
had the same number if they had no
children and they were fresh out of
college with the same degree women were
paid significantly more than men in many
states in many cities they're actually
paid like double digits more than men in
terms of percentage like 10 12 percent
more it's according to Time magazine
2010 widespread wide-ranging study over
pay it's also true that 55% of the
people in college are women 55 percent
of the electorate is women 58 percent of
all graduates of graduate school are
women so this idea that women are being
unaccountably discriminated against on
accounts of their vajayjays is just not
true there's no there's no basis for
that but now he runs that anyway and
then they wonder and then we wonder why
people believe lies well it's because
you see this in in outing commercials ok
that wasn't the only ad that garnered a
lot of attention there's another ad for
a Lowe's has had before I even know it's
called the journey begins and I'm not a
big fan of ads that have nothing to do
with the actual product being sold it's
it's kind of irritating to me but here's
the ad the journey begins which was seen
largely as critique of Donald Trump's
immigration policy again at the super
what's the point of this so as people
waking up and it looks like a Hubble and
looking at pictures
and obviously not speaking English
and they're jumping on the track now
and now they're driving toward the
border and their little girl is very
very happy that she's driving from a
border and now she's reached defends
single barbed-wire fence he's my only
means she realizes she laid across the
fence down there keep in their journey
attorney has continued
she's taking little samples all the way
they pick up a piece of garbage
she's putting up on the lettering
between wonderous in the United States
apparently if she's walking along
railroad ties and picked up all the
garbage it's nicer there's a lot of
garbage my backpack is very for eBay
forget it crossing the river
[Music]
I don't know where they getting food and
water and all of this but this is like
the end of The Sound of Music you sort
of run up into the hills with nothing
and start singing again okay so here
they are they're sitting at a fire
everybody is very contemplative then it
says see the conclusion at journey 84
dot-com 84 lumber and then at the very
end of that ad in the Superbowl version
they come upon this big big wall right
like the Trump wall and there's a big
door that opens and what's then in and
so here's the question um are they
coming illegally are they coming legally
should that make a difference what does
this have to do anything no one knows
and again this is just pandering for
four clicks are you gonna buy something
from 84 lumber now I don't know what 84
lumber is after watching that is it that
what did you see a piece of lumber in
that in that commercial like seriously I
don't know what product 84 lumber is
selling other than like backpacks for
picking up garbage along the road I'm
just I'm just confused so this ad got a
lot of got a lot of clay also on the
left say oh it's a slap at Trump oh
you're right now that you slap Trump
he's no longer president congratulations
you've discovered the secret you ran an
ad on the superbowl about people
traveling and now Trump is no longer
president so congratulations to you okay
so here is the third ad that wheel plane
this one got a trend started on Twitter
that said hashtag boycott Budweiser
but the boycott Budweiser sign on
Twitter somebody didn't know how to
spell Budweiser
so it says boycott Budweiser wis er so I
don't know which beer you're boycotting
but it's not Budweiser so basically
everybody is stupid is the theme of
today's particular Super Bowl show so
here is the ad from from Budweiser that
generated the boycott Budweiser
hashtag on Twitter
you don't look like you're from around
here did you travel across the oceans
presumably is the ancestor of blush I'm
what to prove via his immigration
passport escaped and now he's ending
people are being mean to him he's
traveling out west this is black dude
and he's traveling some more jumping
into a river he was like a real crazy
journey over here st. Louis Sun
beautiful Natalie who's reached st.
Louis
[Music]
thank you the next time this is the beer
we drink never heard a nicer tapas bush
you eat Anheuser and there's Bush and
then they're friends and they make beer
and make really really not great beer
okay so that's the so that's the
commercial so I have a question on this
I don't understand why this commercial
is bad like something is that like the
Audi commercial I understand why the
right is ticked over I really don't get
particularly why the right is angry at
this commercial he's a legal immigrant
it is true that a lot of legal
immigrants had a tough time when they
first got here and guess what the
government didn't help them out and then
they became the most successful magnates
in the history of the United States that
actually seems like a pretty good origin
story for the u.s. right a bunch of
people come here they braved the weather
they braved the people who are jerks and
then they make their way and it turns
out they become some of the wealthiest
people in the history of the country so
that seems like a pretty Pro America I
don't understand why you boycott
Budweiser over that I mean is the
implication that all i'ma grants are bad
because that's weird
again I'm fine with the boy the the
people smacking Audi Oddie smacked
itself in the face they they jumped on a
rake in that ad this boycott Budweiser
one is really silly to me and I don't
see the point I also just think that
generally if you're an advertiser it's
smart to stay away from politics the
best dad actually was apparently that
Melissa McCarthy ad where she gets
thrown into the side of a whale that was
that was sort of the best one we'll get
some Melissa McCarthy later by the way
because Melissa McCarthy had the best
weekend of anybody in America this
weekend other than Tom Brady who not
only won the Superbowl but then went
home to Gisele Bundchen which is that's
a pretty good life right there if you're
Tom Brady plus he's gonna be happy when
he goes to the White House Martellus
Bennett by the way he's not going to the
White House he's another one of these
Patriots players he says he's gonna
boycott the White House again people are
kind of going nuts over all of this yeah
well I remember when there are a bunch
of players who wouldn't go to the White
House to see to see Obama in there's a
couple NHL players who didn't want to go
to the White House to see Obama it's his
prerogative he doesn't want to go to the
White House that's his problem
everybody needs to just take a deep
breath okay so we have to say thank you
to another one of our advertisers now
that ours our advertisers over at Mack
Weldon so if you are in the market for
the best
underwear and if you're in the market
for the best socks in the market for the
best for the best sweatshirts and sweat
pants and comfortable clothing Mac
Weldon is the best of the best they
believe in smart design and premium
fabrics fabrics and simple shopping it's
like underwear as I say socks shirts
undershirts hoodies sweatpants you can
wear it stuff you can wear out its
that you can wear in I am currently
wearing the Mac Welton underwear and I
have consistently been wearing the Mac
Weldon underwear not just since they
became advertisers but even before that
I had gotten a pair and they are they
are very comfortable and they stand the
test of time they really don't fall
apart they are very well made now you go
to Mac Weldon con get 20% off using
promo code Shapiro Mac Weldon ma CK
Weldon wel do n comm get 20% off using
that promo code Shapiro
that's Mac Weldon and again if you're
looking for comfortable where they are
the best there is no one who makes
comfortable better and the truth is you
spend more of your time in comfortable
wear these days than you do in your
actual formal clothing particularly if
you work in the media as I do you spend
like one hour and in clothing that looks
like this and then you get into your
sweatpants look like a homeless person
the rest of the day but Mac Weldon make
sure you don't look like the homeless
person you're just really comfortable so
Mac Weldon calm and you get 20% off if
you use that promo code Shapiro okay so
meanwhile Donald Trump is is back on
Twitter and Donald Trump is also doing
his Super Bowl preview with Bill
O'Reilly routine so this has become an
annual thing I think it's really done it
did this whole routine where we mix
politics with the Super Bowl I don't
know why the president is doing I hated
it when Obama did I'm not a big family
Trump does it look back I was very
critical of Obama putting his face on
every major event in the United States
I'm not a big fan of politicians
becoming celebrities because it seems to
me that our politicians are there to do
a job they're not there to be
celebrities again I think the politician
should be treated basically like DMV
workers except with more scorn and and
that does not seem to be the way that
the United States is moving in any case
Donald Trump does this interview with
Bill O'Reilly before the Superbowl and
in this interview he says a very very
stupid thing and here is what here's the
exchange with Bill O'Reilly it's about
Vladimir Putin and the Lucien's due
respect Putin I do respect him why well
I respect a lot of people but that
doesn't mean I'm gonna get along with
him he's a leader of his country I say
it's better to get along with Russia
than not and if Russia helps us in the
fight against Isis which is a major
fight and is
like terrorism all over the world right
made your fight that's a good thing
will I get along with them I have no
idea there's a killer Putin's a killer a
lot of killers I've got a lot of killers
what do you think our country's so
innocent Oh God and this is the this is
the politics of somebody who's watched
politics for five minutes and again he
may do policy that you like but that
does not justify him saying things that
if they came out of the mouth of Obama
you and all of your friends would be
protesting in the streets as would I
okay you're not supposed to say things
like America is as bad as Vladimir Putin
and we're all killers this is just a
routine as john pat hordes pointed out
this is just a routine from godfather
you remember when Michael is supposed to
be this kind of sophisticated about
politics and he's now becoming the
Godfather and she says politicians don't
have people murdered senators don't have
people murdered and he says now who's
being naive Kay okay that that's the
true teen that Trump is doing here but
the question is to what end right what's
the purpose of it first of all is it
true that the United States kills just
like Russia no it's not true that the
United States is just like Russia no
it's not true in The Godfather that
senators have people killed
if senators could have people killed
I've lived in California my entire life
I assure you Barbara Boxer or Diane
Feinstein probably would have done it by
now okay come on lie here this would
have me on the hit list but that's not
how our politics works thanks good thank
God that would be a corrupt Oleg our key
in which rights didn't matter that is
not here that is Russia
okay Russia isn't oligarchy lots and
lots and lots of Vladimir Putin's
enemies have died under mysterious
circumstances including people who have
been poisoned in in England by Russian
agents here's just a list of some of the
political rivals and journalists who
have died under Putin Alexander
Litvinenko that's the guy who was
poisoned and a poet's Cove Anna
Politkovskaya who is the the journalist
was shot to death in her apartment
building Boris Nemtsov Sergei Magnitsky
Natalia estimate oval Sergei is Schenk
of powell club niqab stanislav markelov
Anastasia Popova
okay so those are just a few of the
people who've been killed under under
Vladimir Putin not all of those is Putin
responsible for we can't say which ones
of those he approved but there's no
question that to be a political
dissident in Russia is a very very
dangerous business beyond which Vladimir
Putin acted as an agent of the Soviet
KGB he said that the fall of the Soviet
Union was the greatest tragedy of the
20th century a regime that was respond
well for the murder of tens of millions
of people and the end the oppression of
hundreds of millions of people he
allegedly green LED a bombing of
apartment buildings in Moscow in 1999
that gave him an excuse to crack down on
Chechnya and dissidents he invaded
Georgia in 2008 for no reason other than
he wanted to grab the territory that
resulted in hundreds of dead he invaded
Ukraine that's now resulted in over
10,000 dead again these are
international war crimes what he's been
doing in Syria they purposefully been
bombing hospitals they purposefully been
bombing civilian areas emboldened
Russian hardliners in Ukraine shot down
a civilian airliner in 2014
gave Vladimir Putin he's manipulated
election results the idea that Vladimir
Putin and American presidents are on the
same par when people do this no I'm
Chomsky routine or they did well Obama
well Obama okay again this is a leftist
routine and you're just doing it cuz
Trump said it can be intellectually
honest here okay I like a lot of things
Trump is doing it's a whole different
thing we're gonna get to some of the
things I like the Trump is doing in a
second but it is intellectually
dishonest to pretend that you would not
be upset if the President of the United
States had a D by his name and was
saying that Vladimir Putin's Russia is
no worse than Barack Obama's America or
Donald Trump's America also I fail to
see how you can constantly say things
like if you criticize Trump you don't
like America and in the same sentence
say America is just like Vladimir
Putin's Russia those do not match up
this is really silly and here's the
problem a lot of conservatives are
falling into this trap of I like some of
what Trump is doing therefore I must
like all of what Trump says so Mike
Pence has unfortunately begun to do this
it's kind of yucky here's Mike Pence the
Vice President of the United States
going after going after media for for
commenting on Trump's comments about
Putin what you heard in that quote was a
commitment to explore the possibility of
starting anew and looking for common
cause with Russia and with President
Putin now you also heard skepticism
there the president said it'd be better
if we got along with Russia maybe we
won't but he's illegally determined and
he told the American people this in the
campaign he's absolutely determined to
explore ways particularly in confronting
and destroying Isis to work with Russia
and and that's the spirit of those
leanings a president speaks with a moral
voice when he's reengage in the country
he suggested that America was on the
equivalent par with somebody
was a killer I simply don't accept that
there was any moral equivalency in the
president's comments look America's
morally superior to Russia what what you
have in this new president is someone
who is willing to and is in fact
engaging the world including Russia and
saying where where can we find common
interests that will advance the security
of the American people the peace and
prosperity of the world and he's
determined to come at that in a new and
renewed way but America morally superior
to Russia yes or no I believe that the
ideals that America has stood for
throughout our history represent the
highest ideals of the time I was
actually at I was at Independence Hall
yesterday and and I stood in the very
room where the Constitution of the
United States was crafted the very
building where the Declaration of
Independence was held forth every
American including our president
represents the world shouldn't we be
able to just say yes to that question
though I think I think it's without
question John it Americans morally
superior American ideals are are
superior to countries all across the
world just say yes my god what the hell
is wrong with you we gonna have to have
the good pens bad pens segments if this
continues again this is what pens did
during the during the debates he also
pretended that Donald Trump didn't exist
so you saw the tape of Trump saying that
Vladimir Putin is is okay so he's the
killer so they're killers here two
people there are lots of killers okay
okay no not okay and there's Mike Pence
pretending that never happened very very
frustrating now I'm gonna tell you what
this exposes about some splits in the
Republican Party in a second but in
order for you to see that and refer you
to see the good Trump portion of today's
broadcast you're gonna have to go over
to Daley wire.com
go over to Daley wire calm right now
eight dollars a month will buy you
access to the rest of the live broadcast
today and every day you can also get the
annual subscription we are in the very
final days of the get a free signed copy
of my novel true allegiance if you go
get an annual subscription right now
this is the Ben Shapiro show and of
course we are the most popular
conservative podcast in America
[Music]